[Musique]
patrick bourgeois des bébés était un
excellent guitariste mais ce n'est pas
lui qui a montré à jouer de la guitare à
son fils
j'ai appris à jouer lecteurs sur youtube
en voulant havlat apprendre des chansons
je me rappelle que mon pas voulu me
donner des coups plus jeunes puis
j'avais pratiqué deux trois fois
ceux d'hiver oomu faire ses premiers par
la guitare youtube a changé la façon
d'apprendre à jouer d'un instrument
un des nombreux tutoriels gratuit pour
jouer stairway to heaven de led zeppelin
compte plus de 5 millions de
visionnements
[Musique]
et cette autre vidéo gratuite et montera
les accords de base atteint 12 millions
de visionnements
youtube a formé une toute nouvelle
génération de guitaristes le premier
patin d'accord que j'ai appris qu'il
fait pas mal toutes les chansons le ceto
seul le mineur fait avec seul à jouer
n'importe quelle chanson est le jour que
ce réussi à jouer une chanson avec kate
a appris sur youtube belle ça donne le
goût dans la prendre un deuxième temps
la preuve un troisième si vous regardez
cette vidéo c'est que vous avez sans
doute on vient de jouer tous ces
immenses classique
les tutoriels de tous genres constitue
la deuxième catégorie la plus populaire
sur youtube pour ce site qui attire au
total près de 2 milliards de personnes
chaque mois
c'est une porte d'entrée youtube les
gens vont toujours avoir la reflex
aujourd'hui en 2019 baver je veux
apprendre lecteurs je vais sur youtube
je veux apprendre le piano un jeu ça
tapait cours de piano sur youtube
c'est un trou des milliers salut c'est
mathieu mathieu tremblay a appris à
jouer de la guitare sur youtube
mais aujourd'hui le musicien de
charlevoix enseigne à son tour sur
youtube au québec dans la francophonie
c'est plus réservé un peu comme par
exemple présentement on arrive à 34
milles abonnés il ya des chances car
dans un peu plus mais oui c'est très
gros
l usage le fondateur de la chaîne je
joue ta guitare constatent les limites
de youtube
la réalité c'est que souvent ces vidéos
sont pas nécessairement adaptée à notre
niveau présent donc c'est pour ça que
moi j'ai préféré y aller avec un site
internet où tout était clan c'est
vraiment étape par étape
claude sirois enseigner la guitare
pendant 50 ans et à la retraite
il adopte et youtube mais avec des
réserves si j'avais eu cette chambre
quand j'étais jeune je vais tripes et
faut pas dix ballons mais c'est pas bon
se découvre en ligue b voyant dans ce
qu'ils dommage qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
contact humain
quelqu'un qui est venue s'asseoir et cie
qui lui prend des cours d'examen avec
moi c'est arrivé souvent que je
m'attelle élèves commencent à vos
professeurs des guitares si youtube lui
dit qu'on sera à pau moi j'en ai console
est plus qu'un élève la main j'avais un
contact humain
[Applaudissements]
quelques années après avoir commencé à
jouer de la guitare ludovic bourgeois a
pu jouer avec son père avant son décès
survenu en 2017
le père serait fier du fils qui connaît
une belle carrière
pour quelqu'un qui a commencé à cette
heure sur youtube jetez pas de me
débrouiller pour vos proies du moins
faire des spectacles c'est ce que je
fais je l'attends pendentif non choquer
pour ça c'est un conte est ici louis
fait dépouiller mais radio-canada
montréal